speaking of getting your little tiny
pencil sharpened down to the base ooh
okay i'll talk about that all day what's
up oh
man feel bad for bryce hall man why
genuinely why this is not like this
isn't that sarcasm i like
i actually feel bad for him and everyone
that participated in that oh yeah okay
wait can i pee
right before we talk about this because
i really want to get into this i want to
learn
about all the puddle
wait no i'm really scared to talk about
this puddle i'm really scared
we're on the way i don't want to get to
the job
they're robbing the bank right now oh my
god i'm peeing i'm peeing i'm sorry
the wheel it's getting away from me
we have to stop i'm peeing
i'm so scared i'm scared i'm scared
i'm scared i'm scared
it's a gun i'm scared i'm so scared
okay i'm going to pee real fast like in
the toilet and then
we're going to get into this you're
going to get on squarespace real quick
on court space
all right guys we're back
imagine some you make your avatar some
like
picture of a girl in a bikini or
whatever you get promoted as speaker and
then it's just uh
you peeing into the toilet
[Music]
yeah you guys i'm squirting right now
hey my name's cindy and i'm going to
squirt
[Music]
wait am i speaker right now sick all
right cool must work
[Laughter]
hope you like it
oops squirt it out of my other hole
right thank you okay sorry take your
[ __ ] pee
man okay so what's the deal sorry back
i'm pinced so all right
this so i watched two videos one by
uh the wade concept one by roundhouse
radio
and they both cover off in the same
situation
which is so social gloves the name
or the name the company the ceo
the named ceo is austin mcbroom okay
and so that's why a lot of his family
members i think were on the card
because whatever that's okay so how did
he start
this company in order to do this tick
tock versus youtubers fight i think so
so he saw the paul brothers what they
were doing and he was like i want to
cash out on this too yeah so he started
that's what it seems
or somebody came to him and said hey we
got this company we want to do this in
collaboration with you
we'll make you a co-founder one way or
the other okay all right so
you know the motive there whatever the
fact is he is named as the ceo of the
company
so um
he uh whatever the wade concept dug up
this clip of michael grewin
and bryce talking to each other saw that
on the
yeah so for those who don't know
basically uh
michael uh bryce confronts michael gruen
because
he's a hot head or whatever and he's
like i heard you were talking [ __ ]
and he's like you said i can't move
tickets and michael gruen says that's
not all what i said what i said was
they're asking you to sell 400 000
tickets he's like
i think that's ambitious for anyone at
50 bucks
a 50 bucks a ticket yeah 50 bucks the
pay-per-view price
and so bryce which is a totally
reasonable thing yeah
like i don't know why you would be
so offended by that it's like that's a
huge ask of
any celebrity at any level listen as
much as
bryce is a [ __ ] i'm gonna excuse the
fact that like
you can be young you can it's you're
allowed to be young and have an ego and
be offended by something that you may
not fully understand it was also in the
context of the
sway reality show the point of it is
yeah drum up drama and they were trying
to make it like the hills or whatever
so it's like you have to have conflict
right so he that part probably part of
it was that too
right so you know but how
rat the dude who has the channel
roundhouse radio
he put it pretty well he said it seems
like
the way it was worked out was these
people would hit these big numbers and
their offers
if the pay-per-view buys exceeded a
certain amount
because josh richards blew it up that no
one's been paid no artist no boxer no
nothing
and the reported pay-per-view buys is
somewhere
just north of 100k 100k pay-per-view
buys
and the anticipated target was like 1.7
million 1.7 million
pay-per-view buys which would have
netted out like close to 100 million
bucks right
mm-hmm and a hundred thousand yes i'm at
half a million bucks
yeah or five million dollars sorry a
hundred thousand
i think is 136 is the rough number
yeah is it five that was closer to ten
just do the math real quick because we
can't do math hundred and what thirty
thousand hundred thirty six thousand by
fifty 136
six point eight million bucks yeah so
it's closer to ten
but and bryce's three point alone was
five million bucks supposed in the ring
yeah so
and that's i mean like you gotta think
the migos performed
a little baby performed big ass artist
yeah
so what's what's wild is all that right
and the speculation or something that
has been heard
is i think maybe josh said this i don't
want to say that because i could be
wrong about that so don't put this quote
uh like attach it to him but basically
there's a
rumor that bankruptcy was
written into the contracts so if social
gloves filed for bankruptcy
they wouldn't have to pay okay okay so
so the whole thing just seems like
a stick and move by austin which is
crazy i i this is where i actually feel
bad for bryce
like yeah he's a dick whatever but
it sucks to be young you can't expect
like a 19 year old to really understand
how to navigate like
entertainment that's not reasonable some
people can some people can't
he signs his contract so now he gets his
ass beat
gets memed to all high heaven you know
the whole addison thing yeah
and now this fool is potentially not
going to make a dollar off of all that
i mean he never claimed to get paid what
do you mean
he never claimed he never claimed to
want to get paid yeah he didn't want to
get paid he never claimed to want to get
paid yeah
yeah yeah but if he just came onto
twitter he's like i actually never
wanted to get
it's cool man i just wanted to do
charity yeah one i didn't want the 5
million
yeah the triple down um i know that that
sucks a great a great observation too by
the roundhouse radio guy was like
the way deji was talking about it he was
saying stuff like
i'm not doing this for the money so if
he's saying like i'm not doing it for
the money
but bryce is over here saying like i'm
getting five million and all this and
that
he's like deji's like a bit more
experienced like he clearly has like a
team that works around what he does
so if that's his you know he's putting
out to the world like yeah i'm
probably gonna get paid like 20k from
this but that's not what i'm doing it
for yeah
so you know it just
when you like look back at it you're
like oh this whole thing was a was a
scam
it was a scam yeah that is crazy those
bankruptcy
written into the contract i mean what
did
so awesome mcbroom posted on his story
right he said he was like
what did he say that number cap uh
you know the haters just want to believe
it like well what was it then say what
it was exactly don't understand why is
it so hush-hush
like didn't logan or jake paul come up
the next day yeah
literally the next morning was like hey
1.3 million people yes
yep like if it's bigger than what it is
then say what it is
yeah why is it hush-hush
i just like if everyone's contracts
already have their fee written and then
why does it [ __ ] why does it matter
that's just so wild cause some of those
kids put themselves through punishment
you know some of those kids were not
boxers that kid michael lee that's
[ __ ] up man
yeah yeah he takes a contract he's he's
not a fighter he's not an athlete now he
has brain damage
yeah no now he took real damage yeah
that that punch is gonna affect him in
some way yeah
yeah okay this is what it says hundred
thousand pay-per-view eyes is cap
only the haters want to believe that if
anything these people who are scamming
if anything these people who are
scamming which with which isn't social
gloves
are basically saying all of us fighters
fan bases ain't [ __ ]
horrible we all know social gloves put
on one of the biggest social media
events in history
as all of you watched the real numbers
will come out soon just know social
gloves weren't the ones
who collected pay-per-view numbers slash
purchases
don't forget how you watched it uh so
he's like putting the blame on
another company exactly and so if it
isn't actually that high it's gonna be
like well they are scamming you yeah
yeah yeah i don't know this whole
thing's so messy
i mean i how could anyone think
that this could go off without a hitch
in the first place people who don't get
piracy or
the internet yeah yeah how could anyone
listen to bryce hall saying he's gonna
get paid five million bucks for this
and be like yeah he deserves that
i mean i think that's the right number
makes sense in my head
economically that would 5 million bucks
for one person just step in the ring
yeah
when i heard him say that number i
thought oh this has to be
some out of touch you know group of
investors that don't really get social
media and they have money
and they're gonna burn a pile of cash
thinking that they'll be able to
make a percentage on it that was my
impression i'm like oh yeah
all these big artists and stuff are
gonna be there so clearly someone it's
you know
clearly someone with a [ __ ] ton of money
who just wants to be in this space is
just going to dump it yeah
i'm like this is this is a dumb idea but
whatever but it's crazy that
no one even no one ever at any point was
like who
who is socialglobe and they just did a
simple search they'd be like
wait what the [ __ ] the headline the
headlining fighter is the ceo
no one's bugged out by this like there
are there are
only a few people who do [ __ ] like that
it's like floyd mayweather yeah
you know one of the greatest yep uh
connor
oscar de la hoya like people who have
like history in the fight game
yeah you don't see anyone on their first
fight you know like
whatever i mean i'm surprised more
people
didn't weren't just tipped off at how
shady this whole thing is by the [ __ ]
name of the company
we said this yeah before how did no one
else be like
how was no one else like social gloves
yeah that's the name of the company
social gloves yeah it's it screams shell
company yes
yeah it's cause it's not like someone's
name it's not like social media
oh boxing how can we
how can we put the gloves or social like
ring no
no that doesn't right doesn't roll off
the tongue does it comment fighting
no no tag yourself
don't get tagged no no don't get tagged
no
um the gloves are social gloves are
social gloves social gloves social
gloves sounds like one of elon's like
shell companies that he
funnels his dogecoin through yeah it did
i mean
it blew my mind watching this
just because i'm like oh this dude knew
from the outset because
yeah i'm gonna tell all these people
like that's like intention bro
i don't think so i don't think he's that
smart no i think that's giving him
a little bit too much credit because i
and i think that's also
that would kind of go against how little
self-awareness i think he has in terms
of like his stardom
yeah he like when i watched his
interview on bffs i was like he
he still thinks he's like the [ __ ] yeah
like listen like the ace family they
were yes they were
huge for like a year or two
right and it's because like people loved
watching their family yeah like women
like you know i'm guessing they're
they're uh audiences a lot of like
children and yeah other family people
yeah right
and now it's like he's just another you
you know you know what i'm saying
yeah no his influence isn't like that
he's not like drake i think he thinks
he's like the drake of youtube
yeah and i like he sat he looked he
looked uh
dave porter in the face he's like i
think he had 1.1.7 million
and i believed him i was like you really
thinks he's gonna get that yeah
i think what so it's that right like he
thinks he's bigger than he is
but you know what it was he's probably
like a dude
who spits [ __ ] out and he makes money so
the people around him go
yeah that's probably possible you know
oh we could figure that out
and so he's like oh if jake paul can do
this many buys
we can definitely do this many buys you
know like that's probably what he put
together off that trailer
yeah so he probably ropes that up and
then his lawyer goes
so have you thought about if this
doesn't work yeah and then he's like why
don't we structure it like you know like
a business person yeah
why don't we structure it like this and
then if this happens and then he goes
into a super confident because he's like
even if this thing [ __ ] fails who
cares yeah like i'm gonna be all right
yeah
yeah i mean i just i don't know i
watched his video like leading up to it
when he was like going to miami and it
was like the you know the video that he
posted on the ace family account like
before the
before the fight to promote he's like on
a private jet for like the third time
yeah going to my and i'm like i just
even if i was worth 10 million bucks
like private jets are 50k a pop yeah
they're not cheap like
anyone doing that [ __ ] like you have to
have guarantee a guarantee
that you're gonna be making millions of
dollars every year for the next like 10
years
for that to economically make any sense
because if it doesn't
then you should invest that money i you
know i'm not going to name names but
there are only a few people that we know
that see take that we see
taking jets that regular i'm thinking of
uh one person who put his name on a jet
that guy yeah you know his bankroll and
that's the guy that's a guy we've seen
to use private jets for a long time yeah
so when i see youtubers and stuff doing
it i'm like there's just
there's only i mean yeah listen like i
know like tana made three
million dollars in one month or
something on only fans it's like then
sure so if you're making that much money
go for it
that's like i mean 30 million bucks a
year if you keep that up you know yeah
if you can yeah
okay then 50k whatever but like for
anyone else like
for anyone like austin who doesn't have
an only fans you know
[Laughter]
he's selling baby clothes yeah i don't
know it's just private jets [ __ ]
freak me out honestly like the the rate
at which people take them i'm like
who is paying for this because no matter
what if it's a company
even then it doesn't make sense unless
you're making unless you're breaking in
millions a year
expensing a jet does not make sense yeah
yeah the only people who like can piss
away that
are like formula one teams
oil billionaires yeah and then uh
and grant cardone yeah yeah it's like
that's literally it but you know that's
that's besides the point
i think it's just no that's not besides
the point i think it screams that
the whole thing just felt more like a
play like
this dude goes uh i'ma fight bryce and
i'm gonna put all this attention on me
and this and that i genuinely think he
just watched the jake paul fight and
goes i want that for myself yep
he did everything in his power to try to
achieve that yep
he doesn't understand that you know only
people who consume youtube
hate him yeah and the world hates jake
paul
yeah that's you know yeah to do 1.7
million pay-per-view buys means like
20 million people were probably tuned in
to be like i want to see this kid get
his [ __ ]
face pushed yeah you're not that bro
yeah you're not that guy pal you're not
that guy
you're not that guy you're not that guy
pal you're not that guy
hey jake paul you want deadpool is
massive yeah him i mean
his brother i mean watch it all be
capped dude watch it i'll be cap
honestly
you know i would be it would be so funny
if austin came out i was like yeah we
did get 1.7
bryce got paid spinny hacker got paid
they're all just balling and he just
bought a second home
and he just bought a second home i
bought it he's like i just took a
private jet
just for the [ __ ] of it just because i
watched your episode and i decided
i'll just take off and just circle la
for a while just as a [ __ ] you
i took a private plane i flew to my orca
and i said take me back home
and i had a uber black drive i had a
driver bring me right here
so i could throw a hundred thousand
dollars at both of you and call you both
broke you know honestly
bless them yeah i actually kind of hope
that happens i kind of hope that happens
less bless it it would just give us more
to talk about i guess
and that would make us work harder maybe
you know yeah
who knows that's that's what it is yeah
we'll work harder yeah we do this all in
spite of
we do this all out of jealousy actually
of people taking pjs
we yeah we worked so hard
to never take a pj just to be mad at
people that take pjs yeah
that's literally it yeah so yeah i just
yeah i don't know
private jets man it's um 50k
a pop at least and that's to go to like
vegas
yeah yeah i think it's something i think
the number is
i think it's like 20k per
it's like it's some it's like
20 30k per like a certain amount of
miles
because i remember we asked that flight
attendant like oh if you took this plane
to like london yeah and i think she like
she's she's like i can't give you the
price but she gave us like a measurement
i think i remember we calculated it
would be like
almost 200 grand or more to fly to 200
across the ocean on a pj
oh my god holy [ __ ]
wild